>>> SKYROCKETING GAS PRICES HAVE
FUELLED A NEW NATIONWIDE CRIME
WAVE.
BRAZEN THIEVES STEALING GAS FROM
CARS, TRUCKS, AND GAS STATIONS
THEMSELVES.
CNN'S ADRIAN BROADUS IS LIVE FOR
US IN CHICAGO.
WHAT IS BEHIND THIS DRAMATIC
SPIKE?
>> Reporter: WELL, GOOD MORNING,
BRIANNA, I SPOKE TO MEMBERS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THEY SAY THE SPIKE
IN GAS IS LIKELY FUELING THIS
CRIME.
AND THE THIEVES ARE BOLD.
NOT ONLY STEALING FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND TARGETING GAS
STATIONS LIKE THIS ONE, BUT
THEY'RE ALSO FOCUSING ON CAR
DEALERSHIPS.
>> THERE WAS A PRETTY STRONG
ODOR OF GASOLINE.
>> THEY SMELLED IT.
BEFORE THEY SAW IT.
>> AS SOON AS YOU PUT IT IN THE
AIR, EVERYBODY SHOULD SEE, THERE
IS SOMEBODY WHO DROVE A HOLE IN
THE FUEL TANK RIGHT HERE.
THIS IS WHERE HE WAS ABLE TO
DRILL ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE
FUEL TANK.
>> MIKE GROSS SAID HIS JEEP, A
TRADE-IN WAS SITTING ON THE
PARKING LOT OF THE DEALERSHIP HE
OWNS AND THIS IS THE AREA GAS
STATIONS USE.
>> THERE WERE MAYBE THREE OR
FOUR GALLONS OF GAS IN THERE AND
HE PROBABLY DID CLOSE TO $1500
OF DAMAGE IN ORDER TO STEAL 15
TO 20 DOLLARS WORTH OF GAS.
>> FROM WISCONSIN TO ATLANTA AND
CALIFORNIA, THIEVES LIKELY
FUELED BY RISING GAS PRICES, ARE
STEALING FROM INDIVIDUALS, AND
TARGETING GAS STATIONS WITH
DIESEL.
IN HOUSTON --
>> YOU END UP LOSING ABOUT 5 TO
6,000.
>> JERRY ON SECURITY CAMERA,
CHASING THE DRIVER HE SAYS STOLE
1,000 GALLONS OF FUEL FROM HIS
FAMILY'S GAS STATION OVER A
THREE-DAY PERIOD.
AT FIRST, HE THOUGHT HIS SENSORS
WERE OFF.
>> IT MAKES ME KIND OF
FLUSTERED, ANGRY.
>> THE SECURITY FOOTAGE SHOWS
THE VAN PARKING ON TOP OF THE
UNDERGROUND FUEL TANK.
>> THEY WILL HAVE A TRAPPED DOOR
INSIDE THEIR MINIVAN, TO OPEN
THAT UP, AND BREAK THE LOCK
INSIDE OUR LITTLE, OUR LITTLE
TUBE THAT GOES INTO OUR TANK,
AND THEY'LL INSERT THEIR OWN
TUBE, AND THEN START THEIR PUMP,
AND THEN THAT'S WHEN THE DIESEL
IS SUCTIONS INTO THE VAN.
>> ALSO IN TEXAS, SECURITY
CAMERAS CAPTURED TRUCKS FILLING
UP WITH DIESEL, AT THIS CHEVRON
STATION THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
THE OWNER TOLD CNN 2,000 GALLONS
OF GAS WERE GONE.
AND THE VALUE AT LEAST $10,000.
>> THIS IS AN ESPECIALLY
EGREGIOUS CRIME WITH INDIVIDUALS
TAKING ADVANTAGEFUL BUSINESSES
LIKE THIS.
>> IN NORTH CAROLINA, THIEVES
APPARENTLY USING EQUIPMENT TO
BYPASS THE TANK, AND MORE THAN
15 CARS PULL UP AND FILL UP AND
GET AWAY WITH $1600 IN FUEL
PROMPTING THE OWNER TO TAKE
EXTRA SECURITY PRECAUTIONS.
>> AND IN WASHINGTON, THE
EVERETT POLICE DEPARTMENT
POSTING A WARNING ON FACEBOOK
TELLING RESIDENTS TO PARK IN A
GARAGE OR A HIGH TRAVELED AREA
DUE TO THE INCREASE IN GAS
THEFT.
BACK IN WISCONSIN, WORK TO
REPLACE MIKE'S DAMAGED TANK
BEGINS.
>> TALKING TO THE INSURANCE
ADJUSTER AND HE SAID HE HAS SEEN
SEVERAL TIMES WHERE PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO STEA